and our Kelly has pleaded not guilty to
the newest charges of abusing four women
including three who were allegedly
underage at the time our Chicago station
wbbm-tv reports police in Detroit are
looking into a new allegation that Kelly
had sex with an underage girl there in
2001 Kelly told Gale that everyone
accusing him of physical and sexual
abuse is lying we spoke with two women
living with him Azrael Clary and
Joycelyn Savage their families believe
Kelly brainwashed them but in an
interview you'll see only on CBS this
morning the two women claimed their
parents have ulterior motives when I was
17 my parents were actually making me
trying to get me to take photos with him
take sexual videos with him all kinds of
stuff wait wait your parents encourage
you to do sexual videos with our killers
yes and they said because if they ever
have to blackmail him what they're
trying to do now they can use it against
him which is exactly what they're doing
Joycelyn I see you nodding a lot with
what she's saying because everything
that she's saying is true
my parents are basically out here just
to give money now the parents the
woman's parents deny ever receiving or
asking for money from Kelly
Jericka Duncan it's outside the Cook
County Jail in Chicago where the singer
is back behind bars
Jericka good morning good morning
Kelly's publicist says that the singer
was ready to pay fifty to sixty thousand
dollars but because he could not come up
with all of the over 160 one thousand
dollars that he owed him back child
support he was sent to jail meanwhile
the parents of Joycelyn savage got an
unexpected phone call yesterday from
their daughter following are Kelly's
emotional interview with Gayle King
mommy Joycelyn savage called her family
for the first time in years to let them
know she's okay
how will we know you're happy when we
don't hear from your two years I love
you Jordan Kelly says he's in a
relationship with 23 year old Savage and
21 year old Ezreal Clary both live with
Kelly that's what I saw on TV this
morning about his way he act when he got
upset I don't imagine what he does in
behind closed doors less than an hour
before savage called her family they
held a news conference urging their
daughter to contact them Timothy Savage
is Joycelyn father but as a parent our
thing is to make sure that she's healthy
safe and sound and make sure she's fine
Kelly said he met Joycelyn after her
father brought her to one of the singers
concerts when she was 19 I didn't go
looking for a Jocelyn Savage I was doing
my show he brought her and axed a friend
of mine to put her on the stage with our
Kelly that is absolutely not true Gerald
Griggs is the savage family attorney at
no point has mr. Kelly ever meant
Timothy savage and Kelly's publicist
says that Kelly was feeling deflated
after being led away in handcuffs
yesterday his publicist also says that
Kelly hopes to come up with all of the
money by next Wednesday gale all right
arica thank you very much